Українським біженцям - час працювати! І чим швидше - тим краще.
Німеччина офіційно заявила про зміну курсу.
Мовний бар'єр знижується. То ж відтепер українцям не обов'язково
мати високий рівень знання німецької мови
і працювати за профілем.
Що зміниться для українських біженців і яку саме роботу
їм можуть запропонувати німецькі фірми?
Головні причини зміни курсу - дефіцит робочої сили
та міграційна криза у Німеччині.
Ми маємо значну потребу в кваліфікованих працівниках у сфері догляду,
зокрема за дітьми, а також у сфері фахових професій.
Ми вдячні, що зараз ми прийняли багато біженців з України,
які також мають гарну кваліфікацію, і ми намагаємося це врахувати.
Ми працюємо над тим, щоб можна було залучати сюди
тих фахівців, які хотіли б залишитися.
За даними на червень 2023 року у Німеччині перебувало
приблизно 480 тисяч працездатних українців,
які отримують соціальну допомогу від ФРН.
З них, за оцінкою міністра праці Німеччини Губертуса Гайля,
близько 200 тисяч українців можуть залишитися
у Німеччині і поповнити ринок праці. Тож міністр закликав
роботодавців спростити вимоги до знання німецької мови
для потенційних працівників. Утім, базове знання
німецької мови все ж залишається важливим.
Мінімальний рівень німецької мови повинен бути на рівні В1
для початку працевлаштування.
Після цього ми очікуємо, що працівник досягне принаймні
рівня В2. Це важливо, тому що всі наші робочі інструкції
та інструкції з експлуатації написані німецькою мовою,
і, звичайно, працівники повинні їх читати та розуміти.
У пекарні пана Едвіна вже працевлаштовані
кілька українських біженців, які добре себе зарекомендували.
Саме тому на ярмарці вакансій він шукає
нових потенційних працівників.
Тоді українською! А що сказати?
Яку роботу ви шукаєте? Будівельник. Ну, я сам вчитель,
але я погано вчив німецьку, не йде мені німецька.
На А2 якось здав. Але я будівельник, ось шукаю роботу.
Я вже старий, не знаю, як бути. Є бажання працювати.
Пан Михайло теж у активному пошуку роботи.
Бо у Миколаїв, звідки він родом, вертатися вже нема куди.
Keine, немає дому… Я з перших днів війни взяв автомат
і пішов воювати. Так вийшло…
Брав участь у боєвих діях у Миколаєві, зайшли танки,
розбомбили і так далі...
Попри поважний вік, 63 роки, чоловік добровольцем
пішов на війну. Та отримавши поранення ноги
через півтора місяця служби - був вимушений змінити
бліндаж на лікарняну палату.
У Німеччині опинився випадково, планував
як короткострокову поїздку.
Думав на місяці 2-3, але не вийшло, не прийняли мене.
У військкоматі. Ви хотіли далі воювати?
Так, але мене не прийняли. А чому, через здоров'я?
Сказали, що я старий, не треба, ідіть лікуйтеся. Це Миколаїв, Інгульський район.
Переживши російську окупацію, Армен із батьком Віталієм
тепер теж намагаються побудувати нове життя у Німеччині.
Я маю диплом будівельника, закінчив коледж у Харкові
і хочу за своєю професією працювати.
Вибір вакансій, представлених на ярмарку у німецькому
місті Бонн, не вельми широкий: робота на будівництві,
в бюро, готелі, спа-салоні, на інженерному підприємстві
та у лікарні. Тож, цілком імовірно, що багатьом українським
біженцям доведеться працювати не за фахом.
Якщо це буде гарна зарплата і робота, яка мені
подобатиметься, то так. А працювати як спеціаліст
з прибирання чи на заводі - я би не хотіла.
У Німеччині Анастасія планує після мовних курсів
вступити в університет і отримати вищу освіту.
А поки придивляється до запропонованих вакансій.
А от Ірина з Маріуполя, яка до війни працювала у відділі
закупівель на "Азовсталі", працевлаштуватися за фахом
у Німеччині і не розраховує: готова йти туди, де буде робота.
Я розглядаю варіант помічника вихователя
у дитячому садку або помічник стоматолога.
Готова працювати не за спеціальністю. Пройти навчання і працювати не за фахом.
В Україні у мене нікого немає, вертатися нікуди.
Тому я намагаюся тут інтегруватися і,
певно, залишуся тут, якщо вийде.
Однак не всі готові до радикального зміни профілю
після успішної кар'єри в Україні.
Що Німеччина робитиме з тими, хто відмовлятиметься
від запропонованої біржею праці роботи?
Звісно, є люди, які не хочуть одразу йти працювати.
Та ми повинні подивитися, чи сприймається це у нашому суспільстві?
Адже ми даємо людям можливість користуватися
фінансовими пільгами в Німеччині,
поки вони не можуть забезпечити собі засоби до існування.
Але рано чи пізно ці люди теж повинні зробити свій внесок.
У якийсь момент кожен, хто відмовлятиметься від роботи,
звичайно, повинен буде очікувати певних санкцій.
На жаль, безкоштовного життя тут немає.
Це означає, що незабаром українським біженцям
доведеться регулярно звітувати про пошуки роботи перед
місцевим відділенням агенції з праці, так званим Jobcenter.
Щонайменше раз на шість тижнів.
А у відповідь Jobcenter має активніше пропонувати їм
вакансії. Тим, хто від запропонованої роботи буде
відмовлятися без поважної причини, можуть скоротити соціальні виплати.
Сумує і одиноко чекає за стійкою пан Мартін.
У нього з пошуком працівників поки туго.
Ми шукаємо вузьких спеціалістів-автомеханіків для нашої авторемонтної майстерні.
Чи вдалося вам сьогодні знайти потенційних працівників?
На жаль, поки ні. Чому? Брак кваліфікації.
Німецькі підприємства покладають великі надії на українців.
Частка тих, хто працює, серед працездатних українських
біженців вже становить 19 відсотків,
і їхня кількість продовжує рости.
Цілком ймовірно, що багато присутніх на ярмарку вакансій
вже познайомилися із майбутніми працедавцями.
Але поки самі цього не знають.
Я знайшла те, що я давно хотіла знайти!
Вакансію інженера. За цією вакансією вдома я працювала 11 років.
Тому планую надіслати сюди своє резюме
і йти працювати після закінчення мовних курсів на рівні В2.
Німецький уряд щедро підставив плече українським
біженцям, але тепер ті, хто втік від війни в Україні,
повинні стати самостійнішими, пишуть німецькі ЗМІ.
Німеччина допомогла українським біженцям,
тепер вони мають допомогти Німеччині.